[موسيقى]
انه الصوت السائد في غزه على مدار 24 ساعه
وثقه المواطنون بهواتفهم منهم من وصفه
بصوت اللعين ونذير الشؤم واخر كتب اشعر ان
خلايا مخي تنفجر
للخوف
بعدم الاطماني الاطمانينه هذه الزنانات
يعني بتغادرش الاجواء بالليل مرهقانا في
البيت في العمل في كل مكان
يعيش اكثر من مليوني غزاوي تحت رحمه
طائرات الاستطلاع الاسرائيليه يسمونها في
غزه الزنانه لما تصدره من صوت مزعج
وفي اسرائيل اسطول متنوع منها هيرمس وجدان
وايتان ونيتسوس
منها ما يراقب ومنها ما يلقي بحممه بامر
من غرفه التحكم هذه
ممكن تقتله وتدمر بيوت زي اللي صار اللي
في التصعيد اللي احنا موجودين فيه الان
نفس هذه الزنانه وهذه الطائره في نفسها
اللي اطلقت على البيوت زي البيت اللي في
رفح بيت غنام نفس هذا صار في استشهاد لكل
الاسره
صوت الزنانه يثير رعب غزه لكن صوت الصمت
يثير قلق اسرائيل
على الطرف الاخر انتظروا هذا الصوت صوت
صفارات الانذار لترد الفصائل بالصواريخ
حتى تنتهي جوله التصعيد ويعود لحياتهم
الطبيعيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات